hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play probably
archery now this is best described by
the developers of course as a
combination between co-op and surgeon
simulators so I'm gonna put that to the
test and see what we got here oh my god
there are more instructions than I know
what to do with mouse to move wrists wow
that is incredible hold Q and mouse to
move shoulder so I'm some sort of
disembodied pair of arms on a sack of
potatoes with a balloon for a head
that's what I've been described as and
that's what I think I am so I'm gonna
ignore that and let's see hold
eetu move elbow and twist arm yeah
that's good real intuitive controls
right here can I just slap two wiimotes
to the side of my face and do this
better oh my god okay hold left shift
move Mouse to Lu the left arm okay and
then you use cuny to do the same thing
on the left one Wow I can't control both
at once this is gonna be phenomenal okay
I'm just gonna set this arm up into
position to nail that target and then
just focus on one arm at a time okay
hold left mouse button to grab and hold
arrow you got it partner I got the arrow
here
what are you with it well it wasn't even
in the bow how did you fire that hold on
do you always shoot off early gah
getting another arrow oh no wait that's
me playing a shot apply shouldn't make
that joke okay so if I got the arrow I
need to hold on to the left and get it
over here okay how do I do this
okay wait hang on hang on a second get
get on the ball get on the ball it's
right there in front of you what are you
doing it's right there get on the
frickin get on the frigging get on the
frigging bow it says when in range of
string oh wait hold rice mom mom I'm
sorry I'm gonna get hep hep okay now is
this good enough oh oh my god oh my god
oh my god it's inverted oh my god this
bow is a communist holy crap it is
inverted this is not going well this is
where we all die this is where the bow
takes possession of itself and turns it
on me and then I get a few arrows to the
face okay wait hang on I've almost got
this
ah yeah I did it I did it everybody
right I got one target okay now let's
gently move over to the next target move
over to the next star you grab another
arrow I'm gonna I'm gonna go straight
for gold and here and try to shoot that
one in the middle over there okay right
mouse button and cue and wow that is
very difficult I'm gonna go for that
sumbitch just just for the wind just a
little bit I need to understand I am
channeling my inner Robin wood and
William Tell if I could just imagine the
Apple on my son's head then I can shoot
his big fat face and collect the juicy
reward no no that's not right
wait hang on pull it no pull it back how
do you pull it back pull it freakin back
not up fire it pull it back why don't
you pull it back a dick okay you better
go back to the no you're gonna go all
the way over there really that's where I
want the arrow pull it there we go okay
now hold the other one and then we're
gonna fire it just comes for the wind
yeah wait when didn't even do a damn
ding-dong damn thing you did Lee Dooley
Dali do okay get another arrow go all
the way over there
no that's wrong that's exactly what you
don't need to do to him never mind
whoa I have overdrawn I have overclocked
my bow far too much and I've just sent a
wave of spit all over my monitor I can
barely see through all the phlegm that I
just unleashed on my monitor but I will
try to persevere how do I aim how do I
shot bow can I kill myself with this
thing that would seem to be a much
better solution than whatever the hell
I'm doing right here aim aim you son of
a [ __ ] aim all I'm saying is that you
need to aim it's really quite simple
okay
fire did I get it did I one I did not I
did not get it okay
let's not aim for goal gold and let's
try to beat this the easy way I say the
easy way what I really mean is the
incredibly stupid way
which is similar to the controls of this
game oh man this is what happens when
developers have too much power and they
actually try to piss off their user base
yeah what's that whoa how did that ah
gah I can't all right whatever you know
what I don't even care anymore
this is absolutely Frick tacular
ridiculous but I don't even care anymore
because I am a professional at probably
archery guessing this is how you train
to murder your entire platoon of archers
when you're trying to go into the
Olympics or something the world's
greatest tragedy about to happen it's
gonna be me all the boneless Olympians
and then that guy from swapping raw
advising he'll get over there you son of
a [ __ ] I'm going to stab you with these
arrows if I could ever get anywhere near
your face get no that's the other hand
get that hand thank you very much pull
it back pull it back all the way I'm
just gonna default all the way back for
every single one of these son [ __ ]
you know I'm not even gonna aim up on
the end straight that's what I'm gonna
do that's how I roll [ __ ] that's how
I roll [ __ ] ah that was right on are
you trying to tell me that I missed that
okay whatever you know what this game
stupid but I'm gonna play it because it
won't beat me because I am far too much
of a gaming professional yeah suck on
that arrow shove it up your butt and go
around the corner I don't care do
whatever you want do whatever you want
with that arrow you've turned blood-red
I'm assuming that means you're dead so
now that's two of one two three four
five six seven eight
hey there's eight targets and two flags
which I'm guessing mean the wind so it's
just a short distance from this one to
the one immediately adjacent so let's
try that one oh good lord
my word
seriously these controls are much harder
than they look but I make it look easy
did I get it I got it yeah I'm a
professional Archer sign me up for the
Olympics Regis Philbin I know you're not
in charge of those but I don't care
that's who I want to talk to I'll talk
to nobody else but Regis Philbin coz I
am amazing no oh oh God
Oh Oh God I've made a horrible error
I've made a horrible error ah no that's
the other target okay what we're gonna
do is we're gonna readjust him Justin
while the wind is gusting gusting I'm
gonna get another arrow I'm gonna put it
on the bow and then we're gonna move the
bow over a little bit no wait something
has happened something could happen
but locked up I can't move I can't move
my muscles my sack of potato patty is
not listening to me my brain in my
balloon head is not sending up the
appropriate signals in order to get to
the to move your arm really you want to
move your arm I'll send you to that
doctor in surgeon simulator I will if
you want me to all use of it okay well I
seem to have lost my mouse so about that
Oh my mouse has died okay I'm done all
right wait a minute everybody don't look
at me but I'm terribly stupid don't look
at this guy right here he's an idiot
okay Mouse back sorry No
what a waste of a perfectly good arrow
okay now I'm just channeling because
it's when I played Skyrim I didn't
really like the bow but I mean I wasn't
bad at it or anything I just didn't like
it so we're gonna try this real steady
like real steady like
into the distance it goes yeah I did it
oh man I'm so good at this Oh like I'm
like legolas crossed with that guy from
Avengers that no one cared about yeah
this is great I'm gonna have the time of
my lot wait what wait what no hey you
shut up there you move a little bit more
- there we go
ah yeah I'm on a roll I'm like amazing
oh man
I'm way better than I thought I was and
I already thought I was pretty good hang
on get over there
key that is pointing in the wrong
direction but I don't care oh no wait
I've done oh I need I need to hang on
wait that is what I need to do right no
that that is very wrong but I won't
judge it for it you do whatever feels
right you do what you want to you do
what you want buddy yeah just like that
is pretty far in the dismount all right
over it I almost had that I almost had
that everybody don't judge me
oh no it still gets shipped down yeah
there we go get it I'm gonna get it all
don't aim at my feet you son of a [ __ ]
if you shoot me in the groin I am going
to be royally pissed off okay that's not
all the way back buddy that's not gonna
go far enough you need to draw it all
the way okay let's let go of it let go
of it let go of it don't what what what
is that that is not correct that is
aiming at your own balls
stop eating oh really really you want to
see fine I should shot myself in the
balls does it look like I care
that's right blow you better or hand or
whatever I mean I'm guessing that I'm
the Frankenstein of potato bags and they
just assembled me from random villagers
throughout the land and then just threw
me up on a post they never expected that
I'd start shooting arrows out of my ass
god damn oh you [ __ ] did it get it get
it not too high not too high all right
all right all right all right Wow
oh that was way off that was my bad that
was that was my fault I am
I apologize sincerely for how poorly I
displayed my archery skills here I liked
a dramatic music in the background - I
guess let's just do some actual game
commentary on that's wrong man the
graphics are just unparalleled in their
realism and grittiness and Jane yeah I
did it oh I'm almost done gimme gimme
gimme gimme gimme gimme Gabbar give a
gotta gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme the
Gabbar doobie move there we go okay all
the way back all the way back I know
you're a little confused at the moment
but that's okay oh all right that if
that's your shooting style
I will not criticize you buddy cuz
you've done good so far okay maybe I'm
gonna criticize a little bit because
this is just oh whoa whoa oh you were so
close
you're weird shooting off the wrist
making the bow go sideways maneuver it
was beautiful but it just didn't pay off
all the way back yes that's it feel the
anger coursing through your veins as you
chip wha what did you just do what whoa
whoa what is this what is it that was
pathetic
you suck are hang on I'm gonna do this
differently we need to readjust that
they're readjusting there we go now
right there get it right there now get
that no that's the wrong one get the
right there get it right there okay the
wrist is still just a little bit off but
that's okay cuz we're gonna get this son
of a gun yeah oh that was so close I
suck I suck lots hep hep yah yah hah the
okay no no no no no no yes yes yeah yeah
warmer warmer red hot red hot oh it was
so close
god damn this is gonna take me forever
ah yep nope there we go
now just aim the wrist it's all in the
wrist these go a little higher than I
think it do then I think it do need to
go a little higher than I think it
didn't go higher nothing I thought I
gonna get get I was gonna get in I'm
just a sack of potatoes
of ongoing attack a potato from my home
country of Latvia yeah I ran away
because I wanted to see everyone start
from potato malnourished okay a little
higher than I think it is no that was
too high what the doctor tada
ah cha-cha-cha okay get it get it yeah
what what are you doing
know that I wasn't even close actually
that was right on target it would help
if I could you know maybe look down the
sights you know I put a scope on this
and give me a platform that I can do the
six 360 420 blaze it a noscope maneuver
it's pretty rad you wouldn't be able to
do it being a scrub noob like yeah all
right now just the hardest one of this
whole freaking game but I'm gonna get it
it's a good thing I'm not on a timer
here or else I would have lost my mind a
long time ago so here we go
way up there I've learned a lot since
last we encountered boo oh I thought
that was gonna be it I thought that was
gonna be the one I'm talking like a
demented Mickey Mouse now yeah okay hang
on no don't do whatever the hell you're
doing what he's doing and just like that
and that's all she wrote no that was
pitiful that was so pitiful you should
be ashamed all of your family should be
ashamed of what that was pull it all the
way back there we go okay now that it is
effectively all the way back
you're gonna launch it oh I can't even
see if it's all Target or nine does it
so unfair oh okay
try it again aim a little higher this
time boom that might have been too high
okay maybe I'm going to high and instead
of a not high enough I'm gonna get it or
maybe it's just that's actually the Sun
and as soon as I hit that one the whole
universe is gonna blow up and I'm just
gonna kill everyone
well good they deserved it for
resurrecting me from a sack of potatoes
what did they think that this was some
sort of quality of
life no Siddeley i turned into duke
nukem yeah it's time to kick ass and
shoot arrows and I'm not nearly out of
arrows or something I don't know I
really don't know that well I'm not do
Mugen okay come on please please please
I'll give you anything I'll do anything
I'll do anything even but stuff I'll do
anything god stop it I'm trying I really
am I'm begging I've gotten everything
else just give me this one just give me
this one you ran the mask mother humper
ah you what humper ha ha ha I did it I
can't believe I did it
who'da thought a little sack of potatoes
with arms in a balloon Fred look
greatest Archer of our generation the
world champion ok really wasn't that
great but I feel like it was so I think
I deserve some recognition here ok
alright so everyone shout from the
nearest hilltop how great an archer
markiplier is and then play the game for
yourself and wallow in misery as you see
how much less good you are than I am
because that was frickin hard that was
much harder than it looked
do anyway thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video
i spurting blood out of your face oh I'm
not supposed to be operating on your
face would it hurt
shut up nurse I'm a doctor course I know
what been all right besides stupid
nurses aside let's continue into the
thoracic cavity our patient seemed to be
losing a lot of blood
very quickly let's try to heal him up
with these 92 significant No
lost another one is another one okay